[موسيقى]
سنحقق النصر وان اضطر الامر ان نخترق حدود
بولندا سمعتم هكذا فجرتها موسكو فهل حان
وقت توسع الحرب الروسيه خارج اوكرانيا
والامم المتحده تدين الروس باغلبيه تامه
وبوتين لم نصب بالجنون بعد عقوبات جديده
ضد روسيا وطباخ بوتين يقترب من التهام
بخموت واردوغان يتدخل ليعلن الوساطه باي
طريقه ممكنه والجنود الامريكان يصلون
تايوان هل اشتعل فتيل الحرب والصين تعترف
لهذا السبب قدمنا مبادره لانهاء الحرب في
اوكرانيا والمجنون يضع الملح في الجراح
الامريكيه معلنا تحديه بهذا الاجراء
العسكري هل من مبارز زلزال يصل حدود
والعالم الهولندي ينبئ بكارثه جديده
مفارم اللحم الروسي تقترب بعد دخول العام
الجديد على الحرب اشتدت الاحداث ضراوه حول
اوكرانيا وظلت هي شغل الشاغله للدول
العالميه هنا الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين يشير الى ان الخطر النووي يتصاعد
لكنه اكد ان روسيا لم تصب الجنون ولن تكون
اول من يبدا باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه تحت
اي ظرف مضيفا ان الحرب في اوكرانيا قد
تكون عمليه طويله اذا فلتملا مخازنكم
بالغذائيه اصدقاء فالحرب لا زالت طويله
جدا الرد ياتي من الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده والتي تبنت باغلبيه الاصوات التي
يقدر عددها ب 141 صوتا قرارا يجدد مطالبه
روسيا بسحب كل
فورا وبشكل كامل ومن دون اي شرط من اراضي
اوكرانيا كما يدعو القرار الى وقف الاعمال
العدائيه مهلا مهلا فانا كل تلك الاصوات
من القضيه الفلسطينيه ياتي اول رد روسي من
مندوب موسكو الاممي والذي قال ان مجلس
الامن تحول الى اداه خاصه لاوكرانيا في ظل
الرئاسه الحاليه لتعلن واشنطن انها ستقدم
مليارين دولار في حزمه اضافيه من
المساعدات الامنيه لاوكرانيا لكن الامين
العام للنيتو يرى الامور بطريقه مغيره
ويقول ان انتصار اوكرانيا على ارض المعركه
هو الطريق الذي سيغسل الى المفاوضات
والحلول السلميه لياتي الدور على الرئيس
الاوكراني الذي قال ان الرابعه والعشرين
من فبراير واصعب يوم في تاريخ اوكرانيا
الحديث مضيفا ان اوكرانيا
البيضاء وقد نجحت ولم تهزم بل ستلزم
الجميع وفق قوله هنا قال الامين العام
للامم المتحده ان حياه الاوكرانيين اصبحت
جحيما حقيقيا سنردون نحن هذه المره فلماذا
لم تروا الجحيم ذاته في حرب العراق
وافغانستان واليمن وسوريا
لنكمل لعوده زيلينسكي ويقول ان انتصار
اوكرانيا امر حتمي اذا وفى الغربيون
بوعودهم مجموعه السبع سجابات للرئيس
الاوكراني مؤكده نيته تعزيز الدعم
الاقتصادي لاوكرانيا في عام 2023 الى 39
مليار دولار بناء على احتياجات حكومه
اوكرانيا بحسب سبوتنيك الخرب تخرج شيئا
فشيئا خارج حدود اوكرانيا ونائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي يؤكد عزم موسكو على النصر في
المعركه حتى وان كان يعني حدود بولندا ولن
تتوقف الحرب في بولندا حيث تهدد موسكو
بالرد اذا تعرضت ترانسيني في مولدافيا
لهجوم بحسب سكاي نيوز لكن
[موسيقى]
لهذه المنطقه الانفصاليه وبالعوده الى
الاراضي الاوكرانيه حيث الحرب الحقيقيه
هنا طباخ بوتين وقائد فاجنر يتقدم في
الصفوف الاماميه لقواته على جبهه بخموت
ويبعث برساله تهنئه للروس بمناسبه يوم
المدافع عن الوطن ليعلن ان مقاتله سيطروا
بشكل كامل على قريه برخيف كان الاوكرانيه
احدى ضواحي مدينه بخموت الشماليه الغربيه
اما الاوكران ومع كل هذا الدعم الغربي
فاعلن وزير دفاعهم التحضير لهجوم مضاد على
القوات الروسيه يشمل البر والبحر والجو
والفضاء الافتراضي وفق
فهل تفعلها كييف حقا ام انها مجرد احلام
لتاتي الاجابه من وزير الدفاع الامريكي
حيث تقال انه على الارجح سينتهي الامر
باحد انواع المفاوضات ويقصد هنا مفاوضات
منتصر لمهزومه او مفاوضات مهزوم لمنتصر
وذلك وفق شبكه سي ان ان لينضم الرئيس
التركي اردوغان الى هذا الراي بقوله ان
تركيا مستعده لحل الازمه بين روسيا
واوكرانيا باي طريقه ممكنه بحسب وكاله
الاناضول ومن هناك عده الغرب نحو العقوبات
حيث فرضت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه عقوبات
جديده على البنوك الروسيه واستهدفت قطاع
التعدين والمعادن الروسي مع ملاحقه اكثر
من 30 شخصيه وشركه من سويسرا والمانيا
ودول اخرى لمساعدتها موسكو في تمويل حربها
على اوكرانيا التي
بينما قالت وزاره الخارجيه البريطانيه ان
العقوبات والاجراءات التجاريه المنسقه
دوليا ستستهدف قطع غيار الطائرات واجهزه
اللاسلكيه والمكونات الالكترونيه
الصين تتوسط الحرب
الحرب ولا شيء غيرها سيحسم الموقف بين
الصينيين والامريكيين فكل الطرق تؤدي الى
تلك الحرب الطاحنه لتعود امريكا الى زياده
جنودها في تايوان من بوابه التدريب حيث
يعزز الجيش الامريكي وجوده هناك وتحديه
للصين فالقوات الامريكيه في تايوان تسعى
لتدريب الجيش تحسبا باي هجوم صيني غرب
اخرى تثير التوتر بين بكين وواشنطن انها
الحرب الاوكرانيه هنا وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي بلنكن يقول وصلتنا معلومات تفيد
بان الصين تفكر بتزويد روسيا الاسلحه
ليطلق بلنك تهديده قائلا انه لا يعتقد ان
الصين تريد ان تواجه مزيدا من العزله
الدوليه فيما تدرس اداره الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن نشر معلومات استخباراتيه تعتقد
انها تدل على ان الصين تنظر في امكانيه
تزويد روسيا باسلحه لدعم حربها في
اوكرانيا بحسب صحيفه بولس جورنال لتضيف
الصحيفه ان الصين قلقه من تداعيات فشل
روسيا في الحرب ليخرج كبير الدبلوماسيين
الصينيين
وينفي الاتهامات الامريكيه بشان تزويد
الصين لروسيا بالاسلحه ووصفها بالافتراءات
مؤكدا ان بكين تسعى للسلام بطريقتها
الخاصه فهل قدمت واشنطن كل هذه الاتهامات
فقط لان الصين ارادت التوسط للسلام في
اوكرانيا
يضع الملح في جراح واشنطن عندما غاب كيم
جونغ عن الساحه قليلا استدعى جيرانه
واشنطن للقيام بالمناورات فعاد المجنون
ليذكرهم بوجوده لتضرب كوريا الشماليه
بتحضيرات الولايات المتحده عرض الحائط
وتطلق اربعه صواريخ استراتيجيه جديده من
طراز كروز باتجاه البحر لتقول وكاله
الانباء اليابانيه ان تجربه الاطلاق
الجديده اظهرت مره اخرى قوه
القتاليه النوويه تلك الصواريخ في بحر
اليابان الذي اصبح مسرحا لعمليات تجارب
صواريخ المجنون لتعلنها الخارجيه الكوريه
الشماليه ان الولايات المتحده يجب ان تعي
انه اذا وصلت ممارساتها العدوانيه
والاستفزازيه ضد كوريا الشماليه ما يمكن
اعتبار ذلك بمثابه اعلان حرب ضد بلادها
وفق الانباء المركزيه الكوريه الشماليه
الاحداث والتطورات الغاء اكثر من ثلاثه
الاف وخمسمائه رحله جويه بسبب عاصفه ثلجيه
شلت الحركه في الولايات المتحده زلزال
بقوه 7.2 درجه على مقياس يضرب الحدود ما
بين الصين وطاجيكستان والعالم الهولندي
يحذر من ان الاسبوع الاول من شهر مارس
القادم سيكون حرجا الكيان الاسرائيلي يرفع
حاله التاهب خوفا من الرد الفلسطيني على
مجزره نابلس الامم المتحده تواجه موسكو
بقراراتها وواشنطن تتحدى بكيهن فالى اين
سيتم جره
[موسيقى]